das Leben würde ich so wie vorher
alles hatte sich verändert
knapp ein Jahr ist es her seit Marcel
Ortel seine Tochter Maria verloren hat
ein schlimmer Verkehrsunfall nimmt ihm
seine 13-jährige Tochter
ich denke mal für 70 80 Cent ist meine
Tochter gestorben genau hier an dieser
Kreuzung
Veränderung für die Sicherheit jein wir
haben schon was getan denke ich ja ich
möchte gerne
[Applaus]
Kreisel wird nicht machbar sein aber das
hier wenigstens ein Blitzer oder
irgendwas hinkommt
das ist
ich will nicht dass Maria umsonst
gestorben ist
nach einem Schützenfest ist ein
betrunkener in das Auto von Familie
ortelt gerast Reue fehlanzeige
er hat sich auch nach dem ersten
prozess-tag nicht einmal gemeldet ich
denke mal man hätte wenigstens meinen
Brief oder sowas schreiben können für
mich ist das fortgetäuschte heuer
Kommunikation zwischen Marcel ortelt und
dem Täter gibt es nicht die kommt auch
nur unter einer Bedingung zustande
er kann gerne persönlich mit mir reden
aber nur das ist meine Forderung am Grab
von Maria
weil er muss einfach verstehen wegen mir
getötet hat
viele viele Jahre leben und so weiter
und so fort genommen
die Person freundliches aufgewecktes und
fröhliches Kind
ein Urteil gibt es noch nicht
marcel ortelt hat ein Teil seines Lebens
verloren alles was ihm bleibt ist um
seine Tochter zu trauern die ihm viel zu
früh genommen wurde